muchas de las autoridades ucranianas
Empezando por el presidente
han asegurado que el ataque masivo que
hubo durante esta madrugada no solamente
en kiev sino en las grandes ciudades del
país es una intención que tiene el
gobierno de Moscú de intimidar a los
ucranianos y volver a crear temor dentro
de la población especialmente en un
momento en que la energía eléctrica se
había ido restableciendo poco a poco y
básicamente en ciudades como kiev la
vida volvía a ser normal en el ataque de
esta mañana hubo ataques no solamente a
infraestructura eléctrica incluida aquí
en la capital sino en otras regiones del
país pero también dicen según Rusia que
también atacaron algunas misiones
militares lo que también está comprobado
y lo que eso sí está confirmado por el
gobierno ucraniano es que atacaron
residencias civiles esta mañana en kiev
estábamos en uno de los barrios donde
algunos de los apartamentos
residenciales habían quedado ata
varios automóviles estaban destruidos en
las afueras que estaban parqueados
durante la noche y así sucedía también
en otro de los sectores de la capital
donde estuvimos habían dos heridos pero
tal vez donde hubo mayores consecuencias
humanas fue en la ciudad de Leví en el
oeste del país una ciudad que acoge a
cientos de miles de desplazados internos
y que si bien ha sido atacada nunca
había tenido tantas consecuencias en
civiles como hoy allí murieron al menos
cinco personas y otros quedaron heridos
Pero eso se ha extendido también a otras
regiones del país a Odessa la segunda
ciudad que fue atacada en 15 ocasiones
durante la noche y también en gersón que
no solamente era atacada por esos drones
y por esos misiles sino también era
atacada desde el otro bando del río como
ya vienen haciéndolo sistemáticamente
las fuerzas rusas Es bien interesante
porque utilizaron 81 misiles esta mañana
de diferentes clases incluido y
Supersónicos de los cuales solamente
utilizan en muy pocas oportunidades
Ucrania asegura que derribó 34 y también
cuatro drones de fabricación iraní
utilizaron ocho durante la noche Así que
utilizaron un alto Rango y un gran
número de misiles para atacar a Ucrania
como no lo hacían hace